قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان هناك
قلقا متزايدا من تاثير استهداف الحوثيين
للسفن التجاريه في البحر الاحمر على
الاقتصاد العالمي واضاف كيربي في مؤتمر
صحفي بواشنطن ان هذا القلق كانت دافعه
وراء انضمام بعض الدول للتحالف من اجل
تشكيل قوه بحريه لحمايه طرق التجاره
العالميه بالطبع قلقون من التهديد الذي
يشكله الحوثي في البحر الاحمر ولولا ذلك
لم تتشكل قوه البحر الاحمر التي تتكون
الان من اكثر من 20 دوله لمحاوله حمايه
طريق التجاره هذا حتى لا تضطر السفن
التجاريه للالتفاف حول راس الرجاء الصالح
مما يضيف اسابيع الى رحلاتها ويحملها
مزيدا من النفقات من الواضح ان هناك قلقا
بشان تاثير ذلك على التجاره العالميه حتى
الان لم نشهد تاثير ذلك على الاقتصاد
الامريكي وهذا سيعتمد على المده التي س
يمر فيها هذا التهديد والمدى الذي سيذهب
فيه الحوثيون لكن بلا شك يمكن ان يكون له
تاثير على الاقتصاد
العالمي